okay so today i want to show
the sleep production that means the
shoot production from the sweet potato
so there is a very nice and easy
techniques that we very quickly we can
produce the shoot from there so i have
collected three types of sweet potato
this is in malaysian variety so this is
called yellow yellow sweet potato
ubiquiladic
kuni and this is called the purple sweet
potato
will be keledek
and this is called a white sweet potato
ubiquitous
so these three types of potato i have
collected from the shopping mall so
today i want to show
how to do
or how we can set for the shoot
production our main purpose is to
produce produce the shoot from that
types of root
that means it is on type of root crops
the sweet potato so this you can see the
any i have used three types of different
cup plastic cup with water just some the
simple very simple the tap waters you
can use
so this is a water calf or any food or
food cuff or even through the water
office and it's a small one
so i have tried to explain that you can
use any type of waste plastic cup from
your house
i have used a transparent cup you can
use the non-transparent also okay the
transport is better you can show the you
can see the routing as well from the
shoot
so firstly our job is to produce the
shoot from there so after producing the
shoot then we have to separate the shoot
and we have to put inside the water
again for the root production
so from the root we can produce
so many shoot at a time so firstly our
job is to cut divide into two section so
in uh in a sweet potato there are two of
end this one is called the uh
top end and the end and this is the
another is what is called the uh
another end
so this end usually connected with the
mother plant and this is the growing
portion this will continue to grow so
from both side we can produce the shoot
but usually
the end portion is usually called this
is the top portion and this is the end
portion the lower portion but both side
we can use no problem but the top
portion is usually they produce more
shoot
and you need just the knife
and the toothpick normally you use the
toothpick so just to hold inside this
cuff so now i want to show you how to do
that
and how to cut and then how to set into
that watercraft
okay so now our first job is to cut the
root under the tuberous root this is
called the sweet potato from the middle
so use a knife and
just you can cut like that
so very
just make it half
so like that
okay
so just to half
so
we can set letter so i want one by one i
am cutting the portion so for this is
called the wider inside the
vessel is white color the flesh is white
color this one is purple color this is
one of the malaysian very popular sweet
potato
so they are flesh supposed to be purple
so this is very nice this
completely purple color so it's called
purple variety
and this one is the flesh supposed to be
yellow color
so cut carefully
during cutting
make it around there
it's easier so this is
yellow
color or yellow flesh
okay so now we have make it two section
so now you have to use the toothpick
this is the toothpick
so
usually is free toothpick for on
so because we have to dive into the
water
so you can take or we can
add the extra water no problem when it's
out also push like that
usually made three
goes like that there's another one
that's right
okay so
now leave here so when the is if water
level is very low
so you can add extra water
just about one one centimeter is enough
so dip into water
so then you have to keep it about two
weeks
this is white varieties we have to keep
it two weeks but
every day you have to check the water
level supposed to be one centimeter deep
into the water if you see the water is
already dried or what is called the
vapor rice so you can add extra water
so this is white variety so we can keep
like that
then this is a i mean
the uh the top space is very more
so maybe we can use four due to the
balance to make it balance
so we can use four toothpick here
three is okay
but to keep the purple balancer exact
balancing
because the space is bigger
okay sorry
you can use another one
okay so like that
as this is water is already low so later
we have to add extra water and you have
to ensure that the at least one
centimeter deep into the water more you
can do that because the suit will be
produced from the top
so this is purple
then this is the yellow
so as this is depending on the top
especially
so we can use the arduino program
okay
and another one
is that free
so now dip into water so this one is
almost okay
so now you have to check every day the
water level and you have to wait
within one week supposed to be they will
start the
shooting
so
after that within two weeks we can we
can see the so more many many shoots
already produced from the
this route then later when the the shoot
is about 10 centimeter five or this cut
eight to ten centimeter or more can also
okay then you have to sleeve that miscut
from the root then the shoe you have to
dip into the water again for rooting
so that means it can confirm after
transplanting
that is that means there is no loss or
there is no dead uh
or the gap from the transplanting so
whatever should you are transplanting so
you can assure that more than 90 percent
they will be survived so this is the way
that how we can do for the shooting from
the sweet potato this is the most
easiest way
and
in any types of convenient uh one in
your house you can do that no need any
the what is called the cold room or
whatever is nothing just
we can dip into water then we have to
wait about two weeks
to produce the shoot from there after
that we have to set for the routing
so this is the silly production or shoot
production from sweet potato
okay so this is how it looks like after
completion so all the three roots is
inside the
water cup with the water and dip into
water is usually you can use more than
one centimeter but minimum you have to
maintain minimum on centimeter deep into
the water
so this is how it looks like
then you have to leave it in any place
at your house but please avoid the
i mean the what
kitchen place or some there is the
temperature is very high in normal
condition you can keep it and just you
have to wait
about two weeks then after that you can
see
the huge suit is already produced from
the top portion of that sweet potato
as very nice techniques and easy
techniques that we can produce shoot
from here
okay that's all
okay so this is exactly after two weeks
so two weeks before i set for the
shooting up this capsule production
so today is already
day 15 actually so that means two weeks
later so
is uh profuse you can see profuse number
of shoot already produced from here and
extra long enough so now
what we can do now we have to sleep that
means remove details the shoot from here
and we have to defend water again for
a reshooting from the
individual shoot
so very nicely there this one is a
little bit solo but it's still very nice
so
this is the way so you can see
how the roots has been grown up
huge number of roots
from the
i mean cutted root of the sweet potatoes
and this is all through the
every single shoot and very nicely grown
and this one is still growing little bit
solo this one
and this one is also okay this is
different variety this one is a
yellowish color
basically the huge number of roots is
already there this is supporting root
just to help the for the shooting
and this is uh the purple varieties
these both are perfect varieties and
there is one other another one was white
so these are already fungal affected so
i have removed that on from here
so you can see the huge number of shoot
that means
sleep production from sweet potato just
by two weeks
then today
what we have to do we have to sleep
remove
just by hand we can remove that truth
and we have to agree in re have to uh
set for the shooting routing from that
shoot
so then uh by one week so just for one
week is enough so balls to one x then we
can transplant in the main field
so this is the called
the should production
from sweet potato quick shoot production
actually very quick
uh so just for tweaks and even by one
week i have tried to see
huge number of this another week just
for the proper growth and development of
the shoot
and we have to do the another week for
the shooting from the special or
individual
this should
so that i can show you now how to remove
the shoot from that route then we have
to set for the
routing from the that branches
okay so now i want to show how to
remove this produce shoot from the main
route then we have to
reset for the
routing from that so just remove by hand
is okay
so just like that you can remove
so this one then you have to soak into
another new water again so they will
produce new wood just by one week they
will produce the roots like that
just remove from the
mother root then
dip into the water
those are
sufficiently grown
so all these sufficiently grown so like
that
we have to remove every individual shoot
from here
then we have to
resolve for root production from that
special or individual shoot like that so
just remove all and this one you just
keep
to see
another new shooting from there
so this is also properly grown
just remove
you can see
they have already started to produce
ruda this small small rooting in its
root initiation from here so very nicely
it's very small small so they will
produce the new root again so when you
can see just by one week is enough so
after one week you can see
they have produced
some of the new roots and the initiation
of would already happen
so now just you have to dip into water
as this one is two different brightest
better use two different uh pots or calf
for the different variety if you have
different varieties this all single body
then you can keep all together in one
cup for the
root
proper root growth from that uh new
shoot
okay there is the some dry leaves so
just remove so this fresh one just dip
into water
okay this one is still growing so i am
not removing that one so that's all so i
am i want to show you the
router
very nice
huge number of routes and the supporting
route that is helping to
produce huge number of foot from there
so this is the overall way or methods of
quick shoot production from sweet
potatoes just by two weeks you can
produce huge number of
new shoot so they should have only given
to water just wait for another one week
so by one week they you can see they
have produced new route from here then
you can transplant into the main field
or whatever you have a special body you
have so just
true
and we have to wait for the root
production from there the remove from
there so that's all about the quick
methods
the shoot production is another term is
called silly production from sweet
potato
okay so just one week before i
set the newly produced shoot into
another fresh cuff for the routing from
there so you can see very nicely they
have produced huge number of roots
now this is completely ready to transfer
into your main field but wherever places
or whatever media you want to grow for
the final grain so meaning is that
one week before i detest that shoot
newly grown shoot from the mother root
and
i
replace into a fresh cup
for the rooting from there
so you can see you can see just by one
week just by one week how nicely they
have produced the huge number of roots
so now you can
transplant this newly grown
shoe root with the shoot so you can see
completely ready to transplant into your
desired media
or in the main field whatever you want
to grow so they can see
very nicely produce the root this is
enough so now you can transplant
so for this this is the easiest method
and we can say this is very confirmed
that while you're transplanting into
your main field this already have huge
number of roots so
it will not die normally if there is any
other environmental stresses there
so this is the nice process very quick
process the slip production or shoot
production from
the
mother root of the sweet potato
and just you can set the root
you can decide for the full or the full
size of the sweet potato into the water
or you can make it to half
and set for the root shooting and after
two weeks you can remove the shoot from
the mother dude and soak into water for
rooting from that newly grown shoot so
very nice very quick and confirmed that
after transplanting it will continue to
grow
okay this is very nice and grow and you
can try at your home and if you have the
planning to grow sweet potato and in and
very well grant that you are confirmed
that
your plant is will be survived
nicely
okay